Luke
Oh top ramen [__] awesome popcorn sure
okay okay perfect oka maikam beverly
hills cop on the playstation 2 a saitek
cyborg x joystick all right a 400-page
book on the history british software i
mean i'm probably gonna need this right
[__] item weight also known as
encumbrance a concept that should be
familiar to anyone who plays video games
the notion that each item in the world
has a weight and that if you pick up too
much stuff you're gonna have trouble
moving around I mean games want you to
pick up things so you can use the
weapons better clothes quest items
things like that but it would be pretty
strange if you can amble around the game
world stuffing your pockets with every
insignificant piece of crap you came
across it could make you overpower it
break the game's economy or even worse
turn your character into an obsessive
compulsive hoarder with an inventory
from hell so game designers put a limit
on us they make you choose what's worth
collecting and what's not but as you can
imagine encumbrance is a divisive
gameplay mechanic some gamers love the
added layer of challenge and realism it
provides while others think it
artificially restricts their freedom
within the world so today we're putting
incumbrance on trial is it still worth
holding on to or should we just toss it
on the side of the road and why oh why
do we find the need to hold on to all
this crap in the first place I mean I
really do think I'm gonna need
games have been teaching us to pick up
things without hesitation for decades
during the classic era most things in
video games could be split into two
categories things that were trying to
kill you and things that could help you
stay alive longer we came up with a
shorthand for these enemies and
power-ups higher ups came in many forums
blue pills mushrooms place of chicken
and so we learned that the chances are
if an item in the world wasn't trying to
kill you it was probably put there to
help you stay alive so item collection
has been along basically as long as
video games and so it went for years we
became accustomed to this fundamental
idea if you can pick something up you
probably need it medevacs red keys
ammunition increments and even as games
evolved and became more realistic this
core principle of picking stuff up
remained over the course of decades
gamers have been programmed to believe
that accumulation is fundamental to
increasing your power it's the loop of
so many games you start with basic items
but by the end you're a walking tank
with dozens of weapons so to use an
example you start half-life with a
crowbar but by the end gordon has an mp5
shotgun two pistols a crossbow grenades
rocket launcher two weapons that haven't
been advantaged yet trip mines satchel
charges a gun that fires a never-ending
supply of alien bees and these bloody
things in game design this ability to
pull a never-ending supply of weapons
out of your pocket is known as a
hyperspace Arsenal a hyperspace Arsenal
is all well and good when you're talking
about games that set reasonable limits
on the amount of items are going to be
picking up and how you're going to be
using them you know stuff like
first-person shooters and platforms fine
but when we talk about role-playing
games games with these vast realistic
worlds with tons of stuff to pick up and
interact with that's when we run into
problems there are several reasons why
incumbrance exists on early platforms
item limits were helpful in mitigating
the amount of system memory the infantry
used it can be used to balance the
overall difficulty of a game it
encourages players to use items instead
of just hoarding them and simply because
having a weight limit on the amount of
things you can carry is more realistic
and there are two main mechanics that
design is used to impose this first
critical encumbrance failure this is
when in games like fallout Skyrim in The
Witcher your character has a certain way
treshold pass which they stop being able
to perform certain actions like maybe
run or travel fast instead of a sliding
scale where the more items you carry the
more tire you get this mechanic operates
at a binary level either you can carry a
ton of stuff with a tissue or you're
instantly way down another way to impose
item limits is the inventory management
puzzle which should be familiar to
anyone who's played resident evil 4 or
the stalker franchise this aims to limit
the size of your inventory by requiring
you to fit everything you own into a bag
essentially asking a player to play the
equivalent of a paused game of Tetris to
utilize the bag space most effectively
it's reasonable to expect that any game
which involves collecting items and
using them to your advantage should
curtail your ability to do so be it for
difficulty or believability or simply to
keep things interesting and while some
players have memories of one system or
another working best for them the truth
about incumbrance mechanics is that like
so much in game design it only works if
other aspects of the game can properly
support it to best illustrate this let's
look at two role-playing games that came
out in 2015 4 at 4 and the witcher 3
wild hunt first up Gerald though garold
could often get weighed down collecting
enemy weapons in the early game this
problem was mitigated in the mid game
for two reasons firstly saddlebags
became quickly available which increased
your weight limit and secondly the world
economy for shitty stock swords meant
that once you turned a certain amount of
gold hoarding these weapons became far
less desirable on top of this the game
did allow you to ride your horse and
fast travel while over encumbered so all
in all the encumbrance in Wild Hunt
imposed realistic limits on the amount
you could carry in fact this game had
other mechanics which reasonably limited
you potions for instance you can only
carry three of them while toxicity
stopped you from knocking back dozens of
different types of potions for the same
effect The Witcher 3 did encumbrance
correctly reasonable limits that added
to the game without imposing frustrating
inventory management onto the player
alright now let's look at fallout
the oft-maligned encumbrance mechanic
from Bethesda's post-apocalyptic
franchise was made even more unbearable
due to design decisions that were
layered upon us for one fall out made
junk valuable all the crap you never
picked up before suddenly was crucial to
the base building and crafting of the
game and what's worse is that most
players couldn't discern what was
useless to them from what was valuable
meaning on top of the weapons and armor
you collect you were constantly stashing
loads of random crap on top of this the
sheer amount of ammunition variety meant
you could rarely go into a battle with
less than four weapon types so if
encumbrance is meant to impose realistic
limits and create challenging gameplay
than fallout 4 fails on both accounts
there's nothing challenging or realistic
about being able to store missile
launchers on your dog so you can make
space for the 86th impacts you've been
hoarding so encumbrance can help or
hinder a game depending on how it's used
and while there are plenty of games that
are set up completely there are other
games that do a great job equipment load
in dark souls 2 affects your roll speed
roll distance stamina recovery and if a
turn off your walk speed and for a game
centered around pixel perfect movement
in position this imposes reasonable
limits to ensure challenge where they're
totally crippling your ability to play
the game the low weight limit in first
person survival game the long dark is
the main reason that game is so
compelling you spend the game so close
to death at all times that anything you
pick up has the potential to save your
life I'm with loot being relatively rare
and a realistic limit on him at you can
carry 30 kilograms or 66 pounds it's a
lot easier to manage plus if you really
really have to you the game does allow
you to carry more than that you just
move slower and have a greater chance to
sprain your ankle the encumbrance forces
you to make tough decisions about what
will help you survive and that's what
encumbrance is all about forcing you to
make tough decisions and experiencing
the repercussions challenge at a sense
of agency are crucially important in
games and that's exactly what
encumbrance provides generations of
video games have programmed us into
picking up every little thing we see so
we need them to pull on the reins every
now and again I'm sure some games
getting conference completely wrong but
when they do get it right it provides
this beautiful added layer of strategy
it makes every decision more meaning
speaking of looks like i'm a bad
80-proof lighter
you